we didn't want it to feel like a british
sitcom we wanted it to feel
um different and um
and so we so that that's that's that's
that's hard
that's hard to find and layla absolutely
nailed that
and um we got very excited because we
were
very tired at that point yeah it was
like it was like one of those moments
where you're like
maybe there's something wrong with the
characters no no no no no no no
i should play
though maybe i said that once and then
that was completely rejected
and then they say no offense ray but i
don't want to direct you
yeah no quite right and leila came in
and it was like
christmas a little bit it was like oh
thank you that was such a good thing it
can be
someone can do that and that and that
and and
yeah sometimes that happens sometimes it
happens really early sometimes it's
really really late and you just sort of
go
oh thank god you know because we don't
have to reconceive the entire
show when layla came in and did naomi it
was very brilliant because
i have to be honest and say that there
are elements of naomi that have probably
come a little bit from
myself a tiny bit like there's an over
cerebral nerve sometimes a kind of
like over-reliance on the on the
theoretical
and need to control if you can imagine
such a thing and
um and i think that must have been you
know
layla's very smart i must have realized
that fairly early on and i wonder what
what that was like
[Music]
oh oh later she's not i thought i
thought she's not
answering that's how i felt um
yes she's she's um fiercely bright
like lucy and um unflappable
and in charge and but also vulnerable
and human and makes mistakes so
it was it was a challenge and and
hopefully quite a recognizable
um person to to see on screen
and a foil to suzy in a way how did you
come to be involved in the project how
did you first come you know
come to hear of it and get involved
well i i sent in um a terrible tape
uh first time round uh as an audition
and i was told that it was not no good
so i sent in another tape
and um because i thought when i read
naomi i was like no i know her
i know her i know how i can do her um
because
as much as terrorist wife and all that
sort of great stuff that i'd also been
put up for was um
in my in my world this was very exciting
and then um eventually i met billy and
then i met lucy and
um i guess something clicked and i was
sort of
a real pinch myself pinch yourself
moment
um of going oh my god oh my god i can't
believe it
because it was brave and mad and makes
you
question stuff and it's just such a
delight to be in it
i think that was the hardest part
to cast i think um georgie lucy
we were we were in all of those classes
we were going round the houses with it
it's a really
it's it's hard it's a hard part and it's
in it's hard to do again authentically
sometimes because
um you know um it's
i don't know i i basically we met
layla at the what felt like a weeks and
weeks of looking
and um she came in and
she had she had all the cerebral
wit and and smarts and drive
but she has this really she has this dry
sense of humor which felt
yeah it was the show it was so much what
we wanted because
lucy and i are very you know also kept
our eye on the fact that there is a
version of this script and it's not uh
um it's not to do lucy's writing at all
but there is a version of this script
where
where these cat where people would come
in let's say and played these characters
and very
broadly and so it would feel like we
were in a sitcom and as much as we love
our sitcoms
we didn't want it to feel like that we
didn't want it to feel like a british
sitcom we wanted it to feel
um different and um
and so we so that that's that's that's
that's hard that's hard to find and
layla
absolutely nailed that and um
we got very excited because we were very
tired at that point
yeah it was like it was like one of
those moments where you're like maybe
there's something wrong with the
characters
no no no no no no no no no no no no i
can play
a little bit it was like oh thank you
it's such a good someone can be
someone can do that and that and that
and and
yeah sometimes that happens sometimes it
happens really early sometimes it's
really really late and you just sort of
go
oh thank god you know because we don't
have to reconceive the entire show
yeah yeah and i think to add to that
it's like we with all of the cast
because we had
we've got a big cast it's like it was a
long process but when they kept like
when dan arrived like
lucy said when layla arrived it was just
like yes
brilliant brilliant actors who can like
step up but
you know we're gonna we're gonna make
something and it's gonna be very special
so it was kind of it was worth all the
pain the waiting i mean we saw
loads of brilliant actors it was just
there was something very magical about
these two alongside you know alongside
billy
um rebecca clark says what do you hope
the audience take away from the show
tomorrow maybe a sense of
um relief although i don't know
yeah maybe some relief that
i don't know i i feel like it would be
nice if
people walked away when i get i i get
that
it's not my life entirely moment to
moment
but i get that and um and and that feels
good
and also has a laugh and also
has a real um
that it's an experience for them because
we we wanted it to feel like that we
wanted it to feel immersive
and georgie does that so well certainly
in the first
two episodes it's like you know
it you you you're sort of feeling all
the fabric and i think that's um
i hope people experience that too
um and then faye watson says is the
series a contained story
or would you like to continue to explore
it in a second series
well we shall have to see i mean if you
catch this
you know well i you know yeah i'd have
to
you know i'd have to come up with
something
and they'd have to want it and people
have to bought it so you know we'll
we'll yeah we'll see but
um uh yeah it's
it's been a lot of fun this one
and and then we've got this just quickly
this one this is really just a quick and
pick up from an anonymous attendee
on the uh improv um leila daniel and
billy
how do you approach improv do you get
much rehearsal time
and you like it
um well georgie and i and
we had some improv sort of sessions
before we started filming where we got
to do
character work which i found invaluable
and brilliant
and that was so that was before filming
and then there were little trigger words
that she would just say to me
and it would get me back into the brain
of naomi which i found
brilliant and incredibly helpful so
that's one of the examples of improv
that we have
yeah i don't think there wasn't we
didn't do a huge amount of
improvising on on set really like it's
the script is so
tight it's so tightly worded and tight
plotted
there wasn't a huge amount of room for
that but i i guess
um in my head there were maybe like two
or three of the really emotional scenes
um between cobb and suzy i remember like
a few where
it was just useful to not have to worry
if
um if you're really going to a dark
place and something weird comes out
there's like a few that spring to mind
and and
um you know but it wasn't like improv so
much as just like a
just a weird little moment or something
that may not have been scripted but it
is
it's all to be honest i mean i love
improvising
um but there wasn't for me there wasn't
really improvising on this it's all just
like it's all
in the writing man um
listen we've run out of time and and i
just wanted to
give the final um question what's not
even a question but tommy dress up who
says
let's all keep dancing which i really
like the sentiment of
perfect that's right um thank you so
much
to you all for taking the time to um to
to join us tonight it's been so lovely
to kind of just pick your brains about
you know this
series which i think is fantastic and uh
it's gonna be available in sky atlantic
and now tv on the 27th of august the sky
original i hate susie
thank you so much to our wonderful thank
you thank you thank you guys
thanks everyone thank you so much stay
safe guys thank you
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you